let's jump into this first story we got
this on Twitter itself from Elon Musk he
says I'm excited to welcome Linda
yakarino as the new CEO of Twitter Linda
Yak will focus primarily on business
operations while I focus on product
design and new technology looking
forward to working with Linda to
transform this platform into X that
every the everything app okay well here
you go
here's a well I guess uh maybe I can
shrink this so you can see it better
apparently not well you can see right
here World economic Forum this is from
her LinkedIn
executive chair January 2019 to present
I took a screenshot of this because I
don't want to show the rest of her
private details but I think this is
particularly relevant and publicly
available yakarino is the chairman of
the world economic forum's task force on
a future of work and sits on the Wes
media entertainment and culture industry
Governor's steering committee she is
also highly engaged with the value in
media initiative
immediately I don't trust her I uh don't
I look I I like Elon Musk I think he's
doing a lot of really important things I
think SpaceX is one of the most
important things humanity is doing
period And I think him buying Twitter
was already very very good but I think
this is a huge mistake if only because
he has shattered confidence in the
platform to the point where I have
pulled up right now the verified orgs
subscription uh plan and before I
clicked deactivate our account which
would suspend payments to Twitter for
the corporate benefits for Twitter
balloon verification I decided to put a
poll up and it's already sitting at 70
saying yes we should terminate our
subscription to Twitter over this so I'm
curious what you guys think
I mean I think that we have to be honest
with who Elon Musk is you know we I we
were talking about how we like to glob
on to someone who we believe is a
conservative because they agree with one
of our values and he's very he's been
very adamant that he wants Free Speech
but he's also a globalist we know this I
mean he's he's made that very clear so
we can't expect that Twitter is going to
be this place that's not going to be
leaning that way or that he's not going
to be leaning that way so I think you
have to do what you think is right for
your company and for your company this
is not where you are for obvious reasons
I'm not concerned about whether or not
elon's conservative right I I you know I
I argue with Sheamus over abortion but I
think in in the modern culture war in in
our current culture War the traditional
pro-choice position is substantially
closer to pro-life than the left's
current position on abortion to the
point of birth which is terrifying to me
so it seems like they're they're
creating this uh the culture War has
created this perception that liberals
and conservatives are almost the same
thing because of how radically different
they are but if Elon Musk comes out and
says I'm going to give the Libertarians
disaffected liberals conservatives the
right to speak on this platform we think
it's a good thing
the issue for me is appointing this
woman says to me party's over
honeymoon's over the censorship will
slowly start creeping back in and we are
going right back to the beginning
I think that I mean liberalism has a
weakness in that it does take other
philosophies at their face value as if
they are honest and right now the like
the woke mind virus whatever you want to
call it the the the current popular
brand of leftism is subversive it's
intentionally subversive so if a liberal
takes them at their at face value you
often end up with modern Bailey
arguments you often end up with all
kinds of uh emotional arguments uh
because the left doesn't fundamentally
believe the same things that liberals do
Elon Musk is a liberal he believes that
open dialogue is always good and I think
that it is but you have to understand
that just because you're liberal
everyone around you does not is not
liberal like people believe that they're
liberal nowadays there are people that
will say they're liberal and then they
will go ahead and advocate for
authoritarian type policies like you
know clamping down on Free Speech you
can't say this you can't say that you
can't have this opinion that's a bad
thing
um and I don't know if Elon is as aware
as he needs to be of how dangerous and
how intentionally subversive the left is
nowadays you can't take people like that
at their word because they are they play
with meanings they play with definitions
um and and I think that if he's aware
it's possible that he could navigate
that uh but it's not easy because people
like that will tend to find other people
like that that share their opinions and
they'll invite them in and hire them and
that's what happened in in colleges in
in education that's why you have such a
monolithic ideology coming out of
colleges now so I want to pull up this
article from vox.com who is Linda
yakarino Elon musk's pick for the new
Twitter CEO and they mentioned that here
let me just read this although yakarino
is not vocal about our political beliefs
it is well known in the advertising
community that she's conservative
according to several sources she served
on former president Donald Trump's
Council on Sports and nutrition and many
have noted that she likes and follows
conservative accounts on Twitter but
she's also drawn flag from the right
some of the more extreme right-wing
Twitter influencer accounts have
criticized her for praising diversity in
the workforce and for being chair of the
task force on the future of work at the
world economic Forum which they view as
an elitist organization I mean that's
putting it lightly they view as can I
mean if you can't go to the meetings and
and just show up it is well I mean it's
a globalist yeah secretive elitist but
uh if she's a conservative does that I
mean is it a good thing is it a bet is
is her participation in the world
economic Forum disqualifying because we
don't trust the Royal economic Forum the
Davos group and their policies what if
she's actually a conservative which
means we're going to get more
right-leaning or Center center-ish
policies
I think it calls for serious scrutiny
serious serious scrutiny uh I'm not
ready to just swear off and say you know
screw off it's it's time to go jump into
the old bunker and and you know expect
the the bombs to start falling in the
end of the world but it is completely
reasonable to look at this person and
say look your history and things that
you've said in videos I've seen clips
and stuff that have been put up on
Twitter already things that she said
it's she is very very suspect so well
scrutiny I guess the idea is
she is well known in the advertising
community and so
elon's view most likely is that she's
going to restore faith and bring the for
the advertisers and bring them back to
the platform but there's only one way
you do that and that's caving to woke
nonsense how how involved do you think
he is at this point I mean it you can
get rid of a CEO she's going to be
tested we're all going to I we're all
going to make it known if we don't like
her I mean I think it's going to be
interesting because
to be CEO you shouldn't really we
shouldn't be judging are you
conservative are you liberal are you a
good manager of something like this and
this is a business if she's managing it
well then it shouldn't be that she's
going after people for their Ideology
Now I don't know if she is in the
situation of being a chair of the world
economic Forum if she's able to pull
herself away from that and look at this
from a business venture standpoint
because if you're a good business person
the majority of businesses across the
world do not look at things politically
we think they do because we see the Bud
Lights of the world but most companies
are like stay out of the political let's
make a profit let's make it work let's
uh let me pull up this tweet from
billboard Chris who responded to Elon
Muskie said during the inter during her
interview with you she was most excited
about your initiative to limit reach of
tweets which are deemed hateful freedom
of speech not freedom of reach in fact
that was her main selling point to the
advertising execs in the audience and
she kept coming back to it she went on
to chastise you twice for tweeting after
3 A.M because people are concerned about
that sort of behavior what she also
wanted advertising execs to be part of
an influence Council within Twitter
she's not here to improve the user
experience she wants Twitter to be a
safe space she represents advertisers
and her natural inclination is to limit
speech and Panda to those who push woke
ideology on the world you will have to
watch her like a hawk she was also
thrilled to spend 100 million dollars on
social justice initiatives at NBC and
forwarded government authoritarian
propaganda that the way back to a normal
life was to wear your mask no doubt
she'll bring in advertising Revenue in
the short term but she's a long-term
mistake Elon responded and said I hear
your concerns but don't judge too early
I am adamant about defending Free Speech
even if it means losing money well I'm
going to put it this way
I believe
in the preliminary view with her resume
is that I should not be giving Twitter
any money and if she then proves she's
going right doing right by the company
then I'll give the company money so I've
already given Twitter some money
signing up for the verified
organizations in Twitter blue for the
company It's relatively expensive
bringing this woman on
I I feel is a very big risk
I don't want to fuel any more of this
ESG woke garbage
if this woman works the world economic
Forum which is a major proponent of this
stuff I am going to limit my giving them
money
maybe in a couple months I will revisit
the prospect of signing back up if she's
doing a good job but this is
I feel like it's
whether it's a betrayal of trust or not
is irrelevant I feel like it's just
advertisers leave Elon says we got to
make money I say don't worry I'll give
you money Elon I believe in what you're
doing he then says okay welcome the
world economic Forum chair on the future
of work and I say oh okay well now I now
I don't know what you're doing and I
don't know if I believe in it I don't
want to give these people money well
okay so let's go a little deeper on the
advertisers leaving thing because why
are advertisers leaving anything that is
considered conservative and why are we
allowing these threats and I think
activists but but they're getting them
de-platform debanked all of these things
and so why are we I see politicians
going after individual businesses and I
say why aren't we going after these
people that are debanking the banks that
are debanking why aren't we making this
illegal instead of going after Case by
case and trying to hit the business go
after the source of the problem and stop
that from happening so we don't end up
having people go I'm going to hire
somebody that I think can get Market or
that I think can get advertisers because
advertisers are so finicky why are they
finicky because we are allowing this
bullying system that is really stopping
people from being able to bank I mean if
you debank someone they're toast yeah so
where are all of the the politicians
that are going well we can allow this to
continue happening thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time